[Music]
[Applause]
I absolutely love college football love
that Tennessee Alabama game I'm I'm
really curious we have uh Rick joining
us
the college football analyst he was in
studio all game for that Alabama
Tennessee game on Saturday where they
even like showed the aftermath for like
30 minutes after the game but I'm
curious Rick like what did you say on
the pregame show what did you think was
going to happen
I actually took Alabama in the pregame
uh I just said you know this is Nick
Saban he is going to have challenged his
defense uh given you know the exploits
of this Tennessee office offense all
season long uh they in Ohio state are
the top of the rankings in every
offensive category and I thought that
defense was good enough to be able to
Corral hen and hooker and Company and it
just didn't turn out that way and and I
think it's also important uh for
everybody to remember that was uh Bryce
young at his best
don't don't say he was hurt he played
brilliantly those were two NFL
quarterbacks going back and forth
throwing salvos at each other uh in that
ball game hen and hooker and Bryce young
will both play on Sundays and play well
on Sundays it was just a great day for
college football and the long starving
fans on Rocky Top they might still be
there Ross they might still be up there
on Rocky Top I don't know they're still
on top it might be more Rocky bottom
right now but uh they're still uh
fervently celebrating that game you know
what's so funny Rick watching that at
the end of the game I I'm very happy
with my life and how it turned out and I
like that I played football and went to
the ivy league or whatever but I would
love to do life again just give me one
more shot just to be a fraternity guy at
one of these power five schools in that
one little hit off one of those Stills
right just let me have one date where I
could just tailgate before the game
enjoy everything by beer and watch this
unbelievable it was awesome so I got I'm
curious about Alabama though I didn't
Saban say last year was a rebuilding
year because I'm watching them think
okay they have Will Anderson back he
should have been the number one pick
last year they have Bryce young back he
won the Heisman last year they have
transfers like Jamar Gibbs I guess I'm a
little surprised that Alabama is as
vulnerable as they appear to be this
year well they're kind of self-inflicted
wounds remember in the Texas game they
had 15 penalties almost cost themselves
a game there Bryce young put him on
their on his back literally as that
corner went over his back and and got
him into field goal range to get that
win 20-19 this game they have 17
penalties
they they continually do it one of them
was a little bit of a phantom call that
pass interference on Fourth and sixth I
went back and watched the film you can't
see the official call it I mean he calls
it when the guys uh Kool-Aid mckinstry
is about 20 yards down the field because
I'm watching for both those the side
judge and the back judge and neither
one's reaching for a flag until he's out
of the screen I mean it was a late late
call but uh and then at the end you know
Nick Saban I think is one of the great
tacticians in all of college football
not only does he recruit the best talent
but he manages games extremely well you
have to run the ball at the end of that
yes you have to run the ball and not
only try to get a few more yards for
your kicker you have to make Tennessee
use their timeouts right without those
timeouts Tennessee can't get themselves
back into field goal range they had 15
seconds as it ended up because of three
incomplete passes and they had timeouts
two of them to be exact if if you use
the if you use running games there there
those are gone and did you see the
Kansas City Chiefs do it again yes as
the City Chiefs at the end of the first
half in 16 seconds went right down the
field so uh a little bit of a mishap
right there for uh say bidding company
correct I mean between the penalties and
the clock management at the end very
uncharacteristic of Alabama as we talked
with Rick new Heisel does an awesome job
as the CBS sports college football
analyst gets to call some games as well
he's always in the studio here's my
question about Tennessee Rick
are they back back because you know how
there's programs that are down and then
they'll have a big game and people be
like oh Texas you know Texas went to the
Sugar Bowl with Sam Ellinger they did
this how do we know if what Tennessee is
doing means they're going to be a top 10
Blue Blood program again for years or
it's like a one-year Hendon hooker boost
so to speak it will all be reliant on
the success of their quarterback in the
Josh heipel system
hypo spreads people way out it's kind of
like what art briles used to do it's a
high school thing right when you don't
have a good enough offensive line and by
the way Tennessee's offensive line was
heroic in terms of corralling a pass
rush that was really non-existent on
this particular Saturday but when you
spread people out you basically can pick
your poison as to how you're going to
play them if they go out and spread with
us we have a running game inside
including with that the quarterback run
hooker's been uh terrific he went for
over 100 yards in the Florida game uh if
you want to play kind of inside and and
be in position to kind of help in that
running game now you're going to get
lots of inside routes whether it's a
slant on a quick whether it's an in
which they hit countless ones or a post
where you run past safeties and they
were able to do that against Alabama the
offense works as long as you have a
trigger man uh I I kind of liken this
team now to what we saw in 2019 with
burrow and Company right Jamar Chase
Justin Jefferson this this receiver core
and remember Cedric Tillman's not
available he wasn't available in this
game when he comes back you put him with
Jalen Hyatt who had the five touchdown
catches uh Bru McCoy the kid that
transferred from USC and that Ramel
Keaton who catches everything I I this
is a really potent offense so I'm
curious though Rick from the Alabama
side does this game even matter I mean
because I was I was actually with a
buddy of mine I was a fraternity brother
of mine he's a big Alabama fan I didn't
even realize it was big Alabama fan and
I said they're still going to win the
SEC West they're still going to go to
the SEC Championship and if they win
that game they're still going to the
college football player I mean to me it
almost feels like it was irrelevant Am I
Wrong maybe Nick Saban's best uh tact as
a coach is knowing which game he can
lose
you're exactly right this was the
crossover game you know West versus East
so he can't afford to lose this one and
get himself in there and think this
through Ross what if uh Tennessee loses
in Athens in a couple of weeks when they
go and play Georgia Georgia goes to the
championship game loses to Alabama as
they did last year and we have three
one-lost teams and throw in Ole Miss
they get beat by Alabama and they end up
with only one loss we have 4-1 loss
teams from the SEC now you can't hardly
imagine a table for four in the college
football playoff from the SEC but if
there were Carnage around the country it
wouldn't be that far outside the realm
of possibility that is amazing who do
you think is the best team right now
Rick
Ohio State
Ohio state looks to have corrected now
we haven't seen the epic game for them
the Notre Dame game right now is kind of
falling off uh the table as a real
challenge even though it was Notre Dame
in week one and so forth but Ohio State
offensively and remember they're doing
everything that they're doing without
Jackson Smith and jigba who's going to
be coming back here soon once he's right
you put him with those other receivers
Marvin Harrison Jr and Company and
you've got CJ Stroud that's been proven
you've got two big time running backs in
Henderson and Williams both when the
others hurt ends up having a marquee gay
and I and I go back to a defense with
Jim Knowles that's been kind of
corrected so if Ohio state does what I
expect them to do they've got Iowa and
Penn State the next couple of weeks uh I
think Ohio State's the best team in the
country curious about your thoughts on
CJ Stroud you know I know that every
player is unique and you can't just look
at the track record of other guy eyes
from their school but watching Justin
Fields last Thursday night I couldn't
help but think a little bit Rick about
CJ Stroud's draft stock I know he makes
some good throws but when you watch Ohio
State Rick he never has a muddied pocket
his receivers are unbelievable I mean
last year Chris olave I mean the Deep
post to Garrett Wilson Chris Lobby
nobody's within 10 yards of them that is
not the way NFL football is and you know
it and I wonder how much that hurts the
Ohio State quarterbacks because they're
so used to a clean pocket crazy open
receivers and then they get the NFL it's
not like that at all well they have kind
of had their way this year and uh it's
one of the reasons I'm telling you I
they're they're my pick for the best
team in the land but if you'll remember
when Garrett Wilson and Crystal Lobby
were having their pro day yeah the guy
throwing to him was CJ Stroud and every
Pro Scout that was there
came away saying Wilson yes a Lobby yes
but Stroud oh my yes
yes oh my goodness oh it was an oh my
session in terms of the balls that he
was throwing he can't downgrade him
because he's got some time but he and
there's plenty of film if you go back
and look at some of the games where he
does make plays in the pocket gets you
know extends plays with his legs makes
makes the big run uh CJ Stroud is a
terrific terrific Prospect right now
right now the two kids in the Tennessee
game are both going to play in the NFL
CJ Stroud's gonna be a big timer in the
NFL and I tell you the kid at Utah cam
Rising I don't know if you saw the Utah
USC game I did he's an NFL quarterback
he kind of you know got the big
shoulders runs like Elway you know that
that kid is a real deal in cam Rising
yeah he had those gutsy runs late that
was an awesome game too it was a
tremendous day Rick thank you so much
for the time really appreciate you
coming on the show wait a minute Ross
you know when I come on Dan's show I
usually have a little song it's you okay
I figured quickly what we do is we just
do a little song that you can have as
your jingle when you're when you're
hosting PPU and DPS you know the cats
away kind of thing it's Ross Tucker in
the morning in ferdan
it's Ross Tucker in the morning in
Portland
it's Who the hell's Ross Tucker he's one
crazy mother uh it's prospector in the
morning in for Dan there you go boy Rick
that was amazing that was amazing I
interviewed I interviewed Rick at the
Army Navy last year and he said I have
some John Madden in me now he does that
Rick you're like I I need to interview
you more I I love it thank you I'm
available I fired football coaches have
one thing in common we're available
exactly thanks so much for coming on
Rick really appreciate it take care my
friend
that guy is awesome you got your own
song yeah I mean and I forgot that he
does that with you guys I forgot that he
has I wish I had any type of musical
Talent whatsoever I have nothing